Rihanna shuts down the Oscar's red
carpet it really feels Like A lot's
happening all at once it feels like
motherhood Oscars Super Bowl that's the
singer who's pregnant with her second
child arriving to the award show glowing
her best accessory her growing baby bump
how you doing how are you how are you
doing
riri's rocking a custom Alaya look which
features a leather halter top and train
it's the same designer she wore Super
Bowl weekend the Grammy winner arrived
with a huge smile on her face an
eyewitness told E.T Riri had a friendly
exchange with an old pal and looked so
excited to be there and that excitement
well it's earned because ree's up for
her first Oscar for singing lift me up
from Black Panther wakanda forever she's
also set to perform it
Lift Me Up
for
fall down
and riri's got her bow ASAP Rocky by her
side the rapper was seen holding a
bottle of champagne as he headed
backstage I'm still pinching myself
really I'm grateful I'm grateful
foreign